NARRATOR: What do all these
people have in common?
They've all been
called populists,
but is that an insult
or a compliment?
And is it even accurate?
It's hard to tell.
The term is defined as a member
of a political party claiming
to represent the common
people, but populism
isn't as easy to understand
as some other isms.
Why?
To answer that, we need to go
back to the origin of the term
late in the 19th century.
The decades following
the Civil War
were a time of massive
growth in America.
From 1860 to 1890, the American
population nearly doubled.
Production of steel and coal
exploded, all while the US Army
battled Native
Americans in a bid
to carve out more and more
land for railroads and farmers
as the country
expanded ever westward.
With over 62 million
American mouths to feed,
farming looked like
a lucrative field.
Technological advancement
made it even easier to grow
and harvest crops,
if you could afford
to invest in the technology.
But many farmers couldn't,
not on their own.
So they took out hefty
loans from eastern banks,
believing that the
high demand for food
would allow them to pay off
their debt in a short time.
But then crop prices
fell and drought hit,
and the privately-owned
railroad monopolies
drove up transportation costs.
Many farmers soon went bankrupt.
The federal government
did little to help,
refusing to break
up the monopolies
and offering little
to ease the suffering.
So farmers took matters
into their own hands,
banding together to
advocate for themselves.
In May 1891, one such
farmers' alliance in Kansas
coined the phrase "populist,"
meaning of the people,
to describe their movement.
Within a year, the
People's Party,
also known as the Populist
Party, had been formed.
It was born out of an unlikely
alliance between farmers,
union leaders, and
workers' organizations
like the Knights of Labor.
Their collective target was
the moneyed elite of the East.
Populist orator Mary
Ellen Lease famously
stated that America had become
a government of Wall Street,
by Wall Street, and
for Wall Street,
and the Populist Party
agitated for massive reform.
The populists called for the
recognition of labor unions,
regulation of the
railroad industry,
the direct election of senators,
a progressive income tax,
women's suffrage, an
eight-hour work day, and more.
These were considered
radical ideas at the time.
Through their collective
action, the party
gained power and a foothold
on the national stage.
In 1892, they nominated
James B. Weaver
for president, who
received 8% of the vote
and captured five states.
Two years later, the party
sent eight members to Congress
and captured hundreds of
state legislature seats.
But there were divisive
factions within.
Nativists and racists
blamed Jewish immigrants
and Chinese railroad
workers for their woes.
Some populist groups welcomed
black farmers in the South,
but others refused them as
the Jim Crow era took hold.
While the movement began outside
the two-party system, by 1896
the Populist Party
had become aligned
with the Democratic Party.
They nominated
William Jennings Bryan
for president, an influential
populist politician.
This too ostracized
many black populists,
who felt a loyalty
to the Republicans,
the party of Lincoln.
The Populist Party waned,
but its founding ideals
would persevere.
Louisiana governor
and Senator Huey Long
led a left-wing
populist movement
that addressed Americans'
real fears during the depths
of the Great Depression.
He demanded a radical
redistribution of wealth
from the country's richest
citizens to its poorest.
His plan, known as
Share Our Wealth,
would have capped personal
income at $50 million
in today's money.
He considered a run
for president in 1936,
but was assassinated.
His ideas, however,
did not die and helped
push the already liberal
New Deal policies
of FDR even further left.
In the 1950s, America
saw one of its first
right-wing manifestations
of populism
under Senator Joseph McCarthy.
McCarthy claimed communists had
infiltrated positions of power
in the government and military
with the help of the East
Coast liberal intelligentsia.
Attacking the liberal
elites echoed the outcries
of the original
populist movement,
but for very different reasons.
In the 1960s, Alabama
governor George
Wallace made a name for himself
as a staunch segregationist.
He used populist rhetoric to
capitalize on mostly white
middle class resentment of
the sweeping social changes
of the decade.
The low and middle income
group in this country
haven't had any representation,
and the pseudo-intellectuals
have taken over the party
in the Democratic Party.
NARRATOR: His followers
attacked the government,
Vietnam War protesters, the
media, liberals, and the elite.
Populist ideas and rhetoric
continued into the modern day.
Barack Obama, responding to the
unsustainable cost of health
care, campaigned on
universal coverage
as a candidate in
the 2008 election
and pushed through the
Affordable Care Act
as president.
The legislation covered many
more Americans than before,
but left the private health
care industry intact.
It was still
attacked as radical.
No more petitions!
Fight the politicians!
NARRATOR: In the 2016 Democratic
presidential primaries,
Bernie Sanders tapped into a
very real anger at both Wall
Street and the government over
the 2008 financial crisis,
the subsequent great
recession, and a recovery that
had left many Americans behind.
As a result of their
greed and illegal behavior,
they drove this economy into
the worst economic downturn
since the Great Depression.
NARRATOR: His proposed
economic policies,
like a progressive estate tax,
doubling the minimum wage,
and improving paid
family and medical leave,
paralleled those of the
populist farmers of the 1890s.
It's going to be so
beautiful, and you're
going to pay far less money.
NARRATOR: Donald Trump, while
running for president in 2016,
also made a populist appeal
to the economic and social
insecurity of many
Americans, portraying
his political opponents
and the media as the elite
and employing a nativist
tone similar to the more
divisive factions of the late
19th century populist movement.
[chanting]
Throughout American
history, populism
has been celebrated,
condemned, and appropriated
across the political spectrum.
There is no easy definition,
but the one thing
all populist movements
seem to have in common
is an appeal to the people
and their fears, anxieties,
and dreams of a better world.